we don't we don't really have much of a
line that's one thing about our show
that we
it's like it's there's nothing off
limits with us i noticed
it's just you what we are we what we are
and
you guys grow up with us and see what
it's like with us in a pandemic
something first ever that we've seen
with y'all you are going into a bubble
and you were going to vegas in that
bubble
you shoot the entire season together in
this bubble how was that experience
y'all
it was cool it was wild because we've
never done that before like you just
said but in the middle of a pandemic i
didn't know if we could even make it
happen but after doing a little bit of
research it comes out you actually can
rent an entire hotel
so i did that flew everybody out
but i had to do it in a safe way now
there's covert protocols
temp checks every day covered tests
every three days it was wild
i tested negative for the kovich
positive but i'm probably
kidnapped they can't show any of this on
tv
insane leave it to the boys
everybody quarantined in vegas together
now y'all get the families involved as
well
kids are coming out to hang out for you
know periods and whatnot now was there a
spouse partner or child that was brought
into the bubble that you guys thought
oh they may not fit into this family
i don't think so not at all no no no
because i feel like
everybody that came in was our family
and um you know you're our family
you're if you're like my family you're
their family and
you know it's never they're an extension
of us so
yeah because they're an extension of us
we respect our roommates so much that we
respect
their partners i'm obsessed with all of
their children
um i would love any of my roommates to
babysit my children
one night i really want to make that
happen um
anything i think it added to it
well like all family though you love
hard
and you can fight hard and we sure do
know
can fight hard and a lot of the stems
from angelina's wedding
last year angelina you're the lice
to my hair
you're gonna fly to our i love that
and you know i know a lot of it's going
to unfold as the season progresses but
uh you know i gotta ask jenny where are
you guys now have you made amends
how was the french i mean i don't know
what you're talking about i had a
beautiful time
it was done so tastefully i've heard the
speeches
went off without a hitch yes
speech of the year that great state is
that a speech that you would redo
and replay yeah and i would burn the
paper
and say [ __ ] don't go up it's not going
there because
well yeah
[Music]
but you know it is what it is i i would
call it the worst
kind of learning experience that you
could have
uh a very unexpected one because
everyone did get to see that we truly
had no malicious intent
that we were just trying to come from
like a funny
very poorly done speech
that um you know we were just trying to
be funny for her
so i think even after the speech
when the months went by and everyone's
gonna see how it plays out
it's not even about the speech anymore
it's just very tit-for-tat
and um you know it was just something
that um i'm glad i kind of went through
to grow from it as hard as it was and as
dark as
it was um you know it just kind of makes
people stronger in the end
and it makes you choose your friends and
your family even more
and it just makes you realize that
man like no matter what we do like as a
group
you just like it gets weird like
you go to a wedding and then it brings
on like a year of hate
and craziness and then it continues into
a pandemic bubble where we have to
relive it in a hotel
that looks like he's shiny and it's like
i'm like what
happened next season i know where you
guys go from here do you feel like
you're
everyone's a happy place with each other
right now
i would say that with me personally and
angelina i feel like it's just
you know a co-worker that
you come together for like the greater
good and there just might be days that
you really don't like the person
and there are days that you really do
like the person and it's just really
coming together
for the rest of you know and everybody
else
and just trying to figure out how to
make it work yeah
i feel like it will all unfold for
everybody to see on the season
very well very well put nina i
appreciate it
now um let's see where do you where do
you guys draw the line as to
what is on or what is off camera you
know is there a line that is drawn and
you say paulie not shooting that
so we don't we don't really have much of
a line that's one thing about our show
that we
it's really real like you really live
with us with like people really go to
jail people really get married people
really have kids people really get
divorced like it's
there's nothing off limits with us i
noticed it's just
you we are what we are and you guys grow
up with
us and see what it's like with us in a
pandemic
exactly probably with a girlfriend too
and your new girlfriend
yes right yes and it was um
it's cool but it's like you know it's a
nerve-wracking thing bringing someone
new to the family
they're tough critics but they're pretty
intimidating people
but they they're great they get along
well so i don't know
it actually worked out we're awesome
they are intimidating grow from like cut
though
uh she did yeah they get along well so
i'm happy about that because that's a
plus if they didn't get along
it can't happen i would have to leave it
all right now ronnie in a sense we kind
of see you start over so are we going to
see that play out this season are we
going to see
you date this season in your bubble i
guess
um i think that you guys are just going
to see me grow
and you guys are finally going to see
that i'm in a happy comfortable place of
myself
and you know i'm just really enjoying
being happy and healthy especially
with everything going on covered you
know i'm blessed that i'm able to spend
time with my daughter
you know and just basically especially
film the last couple weeks with these
guys because we didn't see each other
for
a year and we were around each other for
two years every month for
weeks at a time and now you know for us
not to be around each other and for us
to spend
two weeks together and really come
together and build this thing for you
guys and for us
it's really amazing that's so cool what
what a family vacation now one family
member
we will be missing this season is
uh is of course mid-snooki so
are we gonna feel that absence did you
guys feel her absence you know
on the show this season what was that
like filming without snooki
yeah i just pretended she was taking a
nap
like she was hungover in the bedroom the
whole time she's a huge part of our life
we talked to her every single day so we
even still talked to her while we were
filming
yeah she's texting me right now no she
does not
tell her
[Music]
nice things about me
exactly right well yeah of course we're
going to miss her presents this season
but i think
you guys have a lot to unfold and
unravel with this season of
jersey shore family vacation especially
with all your family members involved
it's going to be an exciting one
to play out what do you think is the the
most
let me let's end on this note who's the
biggest pot stir
of the bunch polly
ooh potts they're a dan that might be me
no it's a dory's little prank
because everybody thinks that paulie is
like the one that is like
so like not in the drama but it's
it's actually complete opposite because
he
like stirs the pot while making it a
joke
but it's so true